please welcome Sadhguru
welcome to the show so I'll give you
thank you I wonder about the title guru
is that is that a protected title or
could anyone become a Sat guru is not a
title it's a description that is if you
want to have your eyes checked up you
don't go to your gynecologist you know
where to go yes so when you say Sadhguru
it essentially means an uneducated guru
that means if you want to know
scriptures you don't go to him
if you want to know religion you don't
go to him if you want to read your
future you don't go to him there's only
one thing he knows he knows this piece
of life from its origin to its ultimate
absolutely he knows nothing else how
important distance is it to have a beard
that was not decided by me all men grow
beard
some men removed only one remote here we
should ask him why he remove does he
have a good reason we're teaming up here
the question
it doesn't make him a guru that's his
choice I should I should I should start
our conversation by talking about your
father because he thought he passed away
so my condolences what kind of
inspiration was he for you he was
definitely a symbol of extreme sense of
integrity I don't know if it's because
of him but I think becoming a seeker of
truth integrity becomes of utmost
significance in your life so at a very
early age I try to enhance my vision
enhance my hearing trying to see and
hear things which others do not hear
normally and see essentially what I
realized was ignorance is a consequence
that has come because most human beings
ignore everything around them it's a
consequence of that so I paid attention
and paid attention so so here now what
what are you paying attention to me can
you sense that I can't this is people
are always thinking paying attention
means something magical should be
happening but the most magical things
are happening right now we are sitting
on a tiny mud ball called Earth it's
spinning in the middle of nowhere
nowhere knows where this creation begins
where it ends here we are sitting and
talking like this isn't this a magical
thing and I'm paying attention even
though I am a microscopic speck in this
universe still I have an individual
experience I can see this as me and see
this as her see this is somebody else
this speck should be nothing actually
but this speck of a thing has individual
experience a sense of individuality
which is such a tremendous thing I think
most people
don't appreciate that they always suffer
that and loneliness has become one of
the biggest problems in the world
because they do not appreciate their
individual nature so would you would you
say that we are too easily bored in our
own company
if you're bored when you're alone
obviously you're in bad company the fact
that we are as a species are aware and
perhaps more aware than the animals of
our time is limited we know that we we
gonna we gonna get old we know that
we're gonna die something really most
people think other people die but not
ourselves yes most people think other
people die they don't understand for
everyone a first time is ticking away
right now as we sit in what you stick
what is ticking away is not the clock
what is ticking away in our life as we
sit here if we know this we would have
no time for doing any nonsense with
ourselves we would do what means
absolutely most to us not silly things
and one thing everybody must do before
they go to bed for a few minutes if they
see their bed as their deathbed you see
that next one minute you're going to die
in this last 24 hours
have you lived this 24 hours the way you
want it if this is the last moment every
day if they do it they will come to
their senses you know some some people
find comfort in religion how about you
one must look at this that the real
thing is that you don't know where you
came from and you don't know where you
go you can believe what you want if
there was no belief in the world if
there was no religion in the world a
whole lot of people probably would not
know how to manage themselves I would
say it's a very inexpensive psychiatry
it's not a solution but for that moment
it settles them
which I feel is important it does a
certain part of the job but those who
are seeking to know life to know the
very nature of their existence then
belief is of no use because belief means
you're assuming something that you do
not know seeking truth means you are
unwilling to assume anything that you do
not know what are you thinking I I was
just thinking you say that to believe
it's it's not a solution but what's the
solution if that is you understand what
I mean you're telling us that if you
believe in something that's not the
solution what is the solution so you
know that in different parts of the
world people believe different things
in one part of the world what they
believe looks ridiculous to people in
another part of the world so belief is a
consequence of social influence it has
no existence of significance only what
you perceive genuinely that's all you
know rest is all your imagination but
how do you actually sharpen your
observations on your perception this
mechanism the human mechanism is the
most sophisticated mechanism on the
planet planet everything that ever
happened to you
pain and pleasure joy and misery agony
and ecstasy even light and darkness is
only happening with the new physical
pain is a natural phenomenon mental pain
is something that you do to yourself
because the way you think and the way
you feel is entirely your choice
why should I turn it off you choose to
feel sad or but you don't choose it I
mean if yes it's there magic muster
enough somewhere like my son died I have
it's off my decision so I'm I don't know
how to to move around that pain and you
are in a somewhere just now I heard both
of you saying it was ten
later to me you were saying that when
you think of him
you're more joyful thinking of all the
wonderful things and that's how it
should be because a life that came into
your life and exited for whatever
reasons you respect that a life comes
and goes it's not our making you cherish
that life for what it's been for you so
the only reason why you value it it's it
in some way it's been beautiful all
right should you cherish it or should
you grieve it well this is not a
philosophy and let me come to that but
right now whether there is joy or pain
or misery or ecstasy or blissfulness all
our emotions isn't it happiness is an
emotion misery is an emotion joy than
emotion suffering is an emotion agony
ecstasy everything is different levels
of emotion pleasantness or
unpleasantness now I'm asking you a
simple question
please listen to this carefully if you
had a choice between being pleasant or
unpleasant within yourself what is your
choice
I take lessons so this guy's you're all
thinking because you're thinking there
is something to it no it's as straight
as this it said that everything that
doesn't kill us make us stronger
isn't that also accurate so if you want
to live by slogans it's fine let's
explore some
but for the pleasantness of your body
for the pleasantness of your mind
emotion and energy it is 100% your
business if you have excuses
unfortunately there are no excuses it's
just that you're choosing to be that way
are you always present within myself
absolutely the question is not about do
you always pleasant unpleasant what
happens within me something else cannot
determine that that's all security we're
way I do you believe your father is now
his soul is now do you believe in an
afterlife or is death sort of a line is
it true that you slowly gathered this
body or a period of time so this is just
a piece of Earth that you gathered if so
much if you have to gather something
more fundamental must be there isn't it
sounds good it it's been wonderful to
talk to you thank you so much
[Applause]
hope you enjoyed the clip for more
interesting conversations please hit
subscribe
you